many self-styled comedians are holding
back on poking fun at joe biden
it seems like they're not interested in
making any jokes that might
alienate the woke audience they built
during the trump presidency
and of course they wouldn't dare
undermine any of biden's radical
policies
you're like okay well we could be making
jokes about
we could be making jokes about the
infrastructure plan but in general i'm
like
this is great i mean what am i why would
i
purposefully undermine something that is
seems to be a great idea pretty much
across the board like i don't
i don't need to make jokes just to make
jokes like i like to make really
targeted jokes there are more worthy
targets right now i think
more worthy targets than the president
of the united states here now is adam
carolla new york times best-selling
author and host
of the adam corolla show adam thanks so
much for coming on with me tonight
thank you is there anything funny about
joe biden
yeah there's funny things about joe
biden there's funny things about
trump there were funny things about
obama
you know comedians have to kind of
challenge themselves so
trump was a big bombastic over-the-top
cartoon character who almost every
comedian disagreed with politically
so that was a layup comedically
now there's biden who's much more
subdued
and they agree with him politically so
now it's time to really prove yourself
as a comedian and figure out a way
to land based joe biden trump is a layup
comedically trump is like getting
heckled by a fat guy and a comedy club
who's got two plates and nachos in front
of him
that's an easy one so they're not
up to this challenge they're not up to
the challenge because they don't want to
be up to the challenge but that's what
comedians jobs are and i would argue
stop doing comedy if you're going to
pick and choose your challenges
well one of the things that we saw so
much over the past four years is this
degradation
of particularly late night comedy where
you had
these writing teams that were putting
out jokes that really seemed to be more
about getting claps
than getting laughter and i wondered you
know if
with the absence of trump if we would
actually go back to having some funny
in late night unfortunately it doesn't
really seem to be there yet because
you know what's the dispute about this
infrastructure plan that samantha b and
everybody else seems to support
well it's interesting you know if you
want to
find the highest per capita
group of ivy league degrees
go to the writing room of a late
night talk show host i mean it's kind of
interesting i never thought about it
i've been in those rooms before
it's yale harvard and brown and stanford
there are no junior college alums
in that in that room so if you i'm just
sort of thinking about this in real time
but it is a
group of people who went through
this sort of elite system of the ivy
league system and then found their way
into a rider's room so of course you're
going to get those
jokes the same way if you had a whole
bunch of guys in that room that did
tractor repair
you'd have a bunch of tractor repair
jokes on
late night monologues you know it really
is uh frustrating to me to see this
element take hold in comedy i'm curious
whether you think
there there's a new generation of people
coming up lots of young comics who are
doing great
great work do you think that they'll be
able to escape this woke moment
and that we'll look back on this as
being something that was an aberration
i mean comedy traditionally pushes
against the norms
and donald trump was easy because he
was the man and it's easy to push
against a man you disagree with
and who is sort of a caricature of
the man so to speak but what i try to
say to everyone in
california and in los angeles donald
trump is not the man
gavin newsom is the man so if you're
going to push back
against the man then push back against
gavin newsom and because most of them
are cowards they go oh not that man well
you don't get to pick and choose
the man right now joe biden
is the man comics do your job push
against
the man thank you so much adam i think
you're completely correct and thank you
for joining me
thank you ben